[Musique]
nous avions l'habitude de lever les yeux vers le ciel et de nous demander où nous étions
dans la rue, maintenant nous
regardons en bas et nous nous inquiétons de notre place dans
la terre, nous devons affronter la réalité
que rien dans notre système solaire ne peut
nous aider neuf ans.  j'ai des enfants professeur combien de temps
serais-je parti huit je te demande de me faire
confiance sept MF tu dois me parler
murf six je dois régler ça avant de partir
tu n'as aucune idée de quand tu reviens
cinq moteur principal
commence, tu n'aurais pas pu lui dire que tu
allais sauver le monde
non Christopher et mat merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous aujourd'hui à Paris pour
ton nouveau film Interstellar je l'aime
tellement et félicitations vraiment
Matthew et Christopher pour cela  celui dont
vous vous souvenez la première fois dans
Christopher euh, je vous ai parlé du
film, rappelez-vous comment vous avez essayé de
bien présenter le film lorsque lui et moi nous sommes rencontrés pour la première fois, nous
n'avons pas parlé du film du tout, j'avais
reçu un appel de mon agent disant
Christopher  non, il a son prochain film
à venir, il est intéressé par toi,
je ne savais pas si cela signifiait éventuellement
intéressé, euh, j'étais l'un des 10,
alors il voulait le rencontrer, lui et moi, nous nous sommes rencontrés
chez lui et nous nous sommes assis pendant trois
heures.  et en gros, j'ai parlé de la vie ou d'
être père, tu sais, je suis père de
trois enfants, il est père de quatre enfants, nous avons parlé de
famille, nous avons le même âge, euh, nous avons
parlé de films mais nous n'avons pas dit
un mot sur Interstellar, rien
sur Cooper.  et j'ai quitté cette réunion et
euh je me souviens avoir été ravi de rencontrer Chris, j'ai
eu une bonne conversation avec lui,
je ne sais pas de quoi il s'agissait et environ
une semaine plus tard, j'ai reçu le script,
alors euh, c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai
vraiment lu quelque chose sur  le film
Interstellar quatre quand tu deviens
parent trois une chose devient vraiment
claire
deux c'est que tu veux t'assurer que
tes enfants se sentent en sécurité
[Musique]
un Je reviens
quand
je t'aime
pour toujours potentiellement habitable Le monde est
juste à notre portée pourrait  sauve-nous
d'Extinction, c'est parti. J'ai entendu beaucoup
de choses sur le film, je veux dire avant de le
voir, j'étais complexe à
décrire le film et je ne pense pas, je veux
dire, c'est une belle histoire juste à propos d'
un père qui essaie de  pour sauver les enfants,
je veux dire ses enfants, euh, le fils et
la fille, vous le pensez et quand vous avez essayé de
faire ce film, c'était votre première
idée IDE ouais, je veux dire pour moi, ce qui m'a attiré vers
le projet a toujours été la
relation entre  Le personnage de Matthew,
Cooper et ses enfants, euh, je suis
moi-même père et je me suis juste lié à cela et j'ai
pensé que c'était une chose puissante, euh très
puissante, de baser ce genre de
grand voyage sur lequel je le vois comme un
film familial, euh, j'ai grandi.  dans un âge d'or
des blockbusters, vous connaissez les films de
Lucas et Spielberg, ces gars qui
savaient vraiment comment faire des films qui
connecteraient une famille plairaient à
différents âges, euh, seraient très inclusifs mais
ne seraient pas doux d'une manière ou d'une autre ou ne
les flatteraient pas.  C'est juste qu'ils avaient tout l'avantage en matière d'
ambition que l'on pouvait
espérer, mais les enfants pouvaient venir
les regarder aussi et je voulais vraiment revenir
à ce genre d'idée de ce que
pourrait être le blockbuster.
Doux jusqu'à cette bonne
nuit, la vieillesse devrait brûler et Rave à la
fin du
jour, rage, rage
contre la mort de la lumière, je
vais bien le faire, oui, tu l'
es, c'est incroyable pour moi parce que cela semble
être un blockbuster, un énorme film et
vraiment  pour moi, c'est comme un
film axé sur les personnages, je veux dire et les personnages
sont importants, pensez-vous que c'est le cas parce que
vous avez fait beaucoup de films indépendants, donc je veux
dire que l'enveloppe semble être le
blockbuster, en fait, cela pourrait être un
film indépendant, je veux dire, euh,
bien axé sur les personnages  comme Chris l'a dit, l'
élément humain est le fait qu'il s'agit d'une
famille, d'un père et d'une fille, c'est une
chose très très simple et concevable, tout
le monde peut comprendre que euh et c'est
le battement de cœur du
film et vous ne savez pas qu'il y a un il y a
beaucoup de science merveilleuse dans
ce domaine nous emmène plus loin dans l'
espace que nous ne l'avons jamais été, mais en
même temps, tout le monde, que vous ayez été
père, que vous soyez père ou
mère, maintenant vous-même, nous sommes tous des enfants
donc nous avons tous fait cet au revoir, nous
savons tous que c'est là que tout le monde
peut à l'unanimité s'accrocher à l'histoire
et ensuite vous vous souciez beaucoup plus du
voyage dans lequel nous sommes. Ce monde est un
trésor qu'il nous dit de quitter
depuis un moment maintenant.  la génération de votre fille
sera la dernière à survivre
sur
Terre, vous êtes le meilleur pilote que nous ayons jamais eu,
allez là-bas et sauvez le monde, j'aime
tellement, en fait, ce n'est pas une grande moralité, vous le
savez à travers ce film, mais vous avez dit que
nous devions l'être.  attention sur quelle planète, cela
pourrait être dangereux pour le futur si vous ne
rencontriez rien pour la planète donc c'était
aussi votre idée, je veux faire
quelque chose à travers le film, je voulais que le
public comprenne pourquoi les
personnages devaient partir, euh et donc
inévitablement vous  vous vous retrouvez en quelque sorte à
prier sur les peurs du public, les
peurs que nous avons tous à propos de ce que nous
faisons à la planète, quelle
est notre relation avec elle, mais en ce qui concerne un
message spécifique dans le film, l'histoire
ne fonctionne pas vraiment comme ça.  parce que
vous savez, comme le dit le personnage de Michael Kane,
c'est comme si nous n'étions pas
censés sauver la planète, nous voulions
la laisser dans cette histoire fictive, nous
disons en réalité qu'il y aura un
moment dans le temps où l'humanité devra bouger
hors de la terre, la terre est le nid
et l'humanité évolue et quitte le nid
et se déplace et prend en compte sa place
dans l'univers plus vaste, euh, c'était pour moi
le point de transition passionnant que vous
connaissez dans l'histoire future auquel
nous avons affaire  avec tu ne peux pas juste penser
à ta famille maintenant tu dois voir
plus grand que
ça Je pense à ma famille et à des
millions d'autres
familles peut-être que nous avons passé trop de temps
à essayer de comprendre tout cela avec
Theory, l'amour est la seule chose qui
transcende le temps et
l'espace, nous avons une mission, notre mission
ne fonctionne pas si les gens sur Terre sont morts
au moment où nous y parvenons,
nous sommes allés plus loin que
n'importe quel humain dans l'histoire, et bien pas assez loin,
c'est une sorte de rêve d'enfant qui fait un
un film comme celui-ci, ce n'était pas un
rêve d'enfant maintenant, je ne pensais pas vraiment
à ce qui se passait comme une nouvelle frontière
quand j'étais enfant maintenant en tant que
père maintenant quelque chose qui se passait
euh des mois avant que je le regarde  le
scénario, mon fils qui avait quatre ans à l'époque
m'interrogeait sur les voyages dans l'espace, il
tu sais, il m'interrogeait sur
le système solaire donc je devais
expliquer ces choses pour la première fois
depuis que je l'ai appris à l'école quand c'était le
cas  mon sentiment d'émerveillement était
alimenté par mon fils et puis ce scénario
arrive et j'ai toujours l'impression de trouver
une comparaison pour tout ce que je vais faire où j'ai l'
impression qu'il y a une raison pour laquelle
cela arrive en ce moment et le
fait que vous savez  mon mon fils m'avait
posé des questions sur ces choses, cela faisait partie de
ma motivation à vouloir m'engager dans du
matériel et aussi après avoir lu l'
histoire, j'ai eu un certain sentiment de fierté et en
disant que c'est le genre de film que je veux
faire et que je veux que mes enfants  pour voir ce qu'il
dit sur la
capacité de l'humanité sur ce qu'il dit sur ce que
nous sommes capables de faire euh et d'
exploration
Discovery murf est une enfant géniale, elle est
vraiment intelligente mais elle a eu un
peu de mal ces derniers temps, elle a introduit ça
pour montrer aux autres étudiants la
section sur les alunissages ouais, c'est
un de mes vieux
manuels, elle a toujours adoré les images,
c'est un vieux manuel fédéral, nous
les avons remplacés par les
versions corrigées, expliquant comment les
missions Apollo étaient fausses pour mettre
l'
Union soviétique en faillite  vous ne croyez pas que nous sommes allés sur la
lune, je crois que c'était une brillante
propagande selon laquelle les Soviétiques
se sont eux-mêmes mis en faillite en investissant des ressources
dans des fusées et d'autres machines inutiles, des
machines inutiles et si nous ne voulons pas
répéter l'excès et le gaspillage de
la  Au 20ème siècle, nous devons enseigner à
nos enfants cette planète, pas les histoires de son
départ,
vous savez, une de ces
machines inutiles qu'ils fabriquaient s'appelait une
IRM et s'il nous en restait, les
médecins auraient pu trouver le
kyste.  dans le cerveau de ma femme avant sa mort,
mais après, c'est elle qui aurait
été assise là à écouter
ça à ma place, ce qui a été une bonne
chose car elle a toujours été la plus calme,
l'éducation est aussi pour moi le
thème du  le film était l'ONU, je veux dire,
bien faire une bonne éducation, dans un sens plus large,
je pense que je pense que c'est beaucoup une question de
communication, certainement, c'est beaucoup une
question de vérité, je suppose, euh, je veux dire, la
scène dans l'école au début est, je
pense, très importante  un des thèmes
du film quand vous savez que Cooper est
confronté au professeur de sa fille
qui nie que les alunissages aient
jamais eu lieu et que c'est le
monde dans lequel ils vivent et et je pense,
euh, je
pense que cela définit immédiatement les
termes  dans le sens de dire euh
vous savez que l'histoire peut être réécrite peut être
couverte ou quoi que ce soit d'autre euh et l'
importance de ne pas permettre que cela se
produise, l'importance de transmettre les
connaissances et de s'appuyer sur l'
expérience humaine et les connaissances humaines parce que je
pense qu'en fin de compte,
le  le film parle de l'évolution humaine, il
suggère ce qui pourrait être la prochaine grande
étape de l'évolution humaine qui se déroulerait hors de la
planète et cela nécessitera
la connaissance de la connaissance cumulative d'une
espèce et d'une civilisation entières et nous
ne pouvons pas perdre la connaissance au fur et à mesure, nous devons
construire dessus et construire dessus et construire
dessus euh et je pense que c'est le genre de
voyage vers l'extérieur vraiment
de la race humaine dans le film je ne vais pas
le faire oui tu l'es oui tu l'es
tu pourrais avoir  pour décider entre revoir
vos enfants
et l'avenir de la
race humaine, nous trouverons un moyen pour que vous ayez exactement la
vision du film dans votre esprit pendant le
tournage, euh les couloirs, pas trop
spécifiquement, euh, j'aime impliquer
tout le monde, j'aime avoir le  les acteurs là-bas
voient comment ils veulent se déplacer dans une
scène. J'aurai certaines idées sur la
façon dont je veux la filmer, mais je veux que
mon directeur de la photographie, mes acteurs,
tout le monde, vous voulez trouver des choses le
jour où c'est ce qui le rend intéressant et
quoi.
ça continue d'être plus que ce à quoi je pourrais penser
parce que tout ce que j'y mets est le
pouvoir cérébral d'un homme, vous savez, la créativité d'un homme
si vous pouvez amener des centaines de
personnes à se concentrer toutes sur la même chose, à
concentrer leur énergie sur la même chose,
euh, il y a juste  vous pouvez faire tellement plus
et j'essaie donc d'avoir une idée de ce dont j'ai
besoin et de ce dont l'histoire a besoin,
mais chaque jour, vous cherchez
quelque chose de nouveau, vous cherchez
quelque chose de nouveau de la part des personnes avec lesquelles vous
travaillez, alors  la chose la plus importante
pour vous c'est de travailler avec les acteurs en
fait, pas seulement le tournage avec
des effets spéciaux ou quelque chose comme ça,
c'est travailler avec les acteurs, définitivement,
je veux dire, l'élément humain est ce qui maintient
le public intéressé par les films dans une
histoire, c'est  ce qui m'intéresse
dans la réalisation de films, je pense que c'est
fascinant, je veux dire, ce que font ces gars est
incroyable et mystérieux pour moi et euh, j'espère que
cela restera toujours
mystérieux,
qu'est-ce que tu vas en faire, je
vais lui donner quelque chose de social
responsable de faire on ne peut pas laisser
tomber ce truc doit apprendre à
s'adapter M gang
masquons-nous comme le reste matud tu as fait quelques
recherches avant de tirer sur pas vraiment
et Christopher à toi de faire des
recherches ou pas du tout  Oui euh je veux dire,
j'ai passé du temps avec Kip Dorne
l'astrophysicien M juste pour en quelque sorte
comprendre quelques grandes lignes des
plausibilités euh scientifiquement qui
sont dans ce film, j'ai parlé
à l'astronaute, je pense que le premier livre que
vous m'avez remis était  les bonnes choses ouais, fais attention,
regarde le premier chapitre avec
Jagger euh en tant que pilote, sa voix Etc euh
et puis je veux dire, quotidiennement, j'essayais de me
mettre dans la tête quotidiennement pour y aller, ok, quelles
sont les règles de cette géographie
et je  j'ai besoin de savoir en tant qu'acteur mais j'ai
aussi besoin de savoir qu'en tant que pilote, j'ai une
équipe dont je dois m'occuper et c'était mes
conversations préférées, ça va et vient
oh ouais, il était pour moi comme son fils l'
est pour lui, il est comme pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi  attends une
seconde pourquoi L de question, rien ne le prends
pour acquis euh mais j'apprécie le fait que je veux dire
en tant que réalisateur, en particulier en tant que scénariste-
réalisateur, cela vous tient en
haleine, cela vous fait réfléchir à la raison pour laquelle vous
avez fait quelque chose en premier lieu parce que  Je
veux dire, ce qui est drôle, c'est que lorsque vous êtes sur
le plateau avec votre scénario, cela fait souvent
plusieurs mois que vous avez écrit la
scène et c'est en fait une très bonne
chose d'être ramené dans le
bon sens et pourquoi, d'accord, comment cette
scène est-elle arrivée ?  à propos de ce que cette scène est
censée faire 76 vous allez
faire en sorte que l'Inconnu
[Musique]
Connu compte ces moments comme nos
réalisations les plus fières après avoir enflammé l'
imagination d'une génération mais nous avons perdu
tout ce qui tenait au port pour la dernière
fois ou peut-être que nous  J'ai juste
oublié que nous sommes encore
des Pionniers, que nous venons à peine de
commencer et que nos plus grandes
réalisations ne peuvent pas être derrière
nous parce que notre
destin est au-dessus de nous.
[Musique]
Ce qui a été la chose la plus difficile pour
vous de faire sur ce film était quelque chose de
spécial, pas  vraiment bien pour moi, je veux dire, sur le plan
créatif, le plus grand défi était
définitivement d'essayer de visualiser des choses
qui dans le scénario étaient très abstraites,
très complexes et difficiles d'imaginer
comment nous allions le tourner quand j'écris sur
le scénario. J'essaie de ne pas écrire en tant que
réalisateur.  J'essaie de ne pas trop savoir
comment je vais faire le film donc
je ne veux pas limiter l'écriture, puis
quand c'est fait en tant que réalisateur, vous
y arrivez et vous regardez, vous dites que je n'ai aucune
idée de comment faire.  visualisez cela, je ne sais pas comment
nous allons faire cela, mais c'est là que
vous rassemblez votre équipe, euh et vous vous
débattez tous autour, vous en parlez et
vous essayez des choses et vous essayez des choses
et euh, le côté effets visuels des choses est
très délicat.  ce film, euh, beaucoup de
choses que je n'avais jamais faites avant, j'essaie
d'avoir une idée de la réalité, vraiment.
U, le vol spatial pour moi, des choses comme
le trou noir qui est dans le film,
vous savez, c'est le genre de chose qui a été
fait dans des films auparavant, donc vous
cherchez une nouvelle approche, mais nous
cherchions également à essayer de le faire d'une manière qui
était scientifiquement vraiment incroyable et c'est là que
notre producteur exécutif Kip
Thorne est venu parce qu'il était
capable de donner  nous les équations réelles sur l'
apparence d'un trou noir, comment sa
gravité affecterait la lumière et l'
espace-temps autour de lui, donnent cela à nos
cieux à effet visuel et ils pourraient
rendre le trou noir tel qu'il
apparaîtrait dans la
vie réelle.  doit affronter la
réalité du
voyage interstellaire murf Je t'aime pour toujours
[Musique]
as-tu le film de J Lucas ou le
film kuric ou le film d'Alonso Crowan comme
référence, tu essaies d'oublier
immédiatement ces films et bien je tu connais
Alfonso je lui ai avoué timidement en
dernier  année que je suis la seule à
ne pas avoir vu ce film parce que je ne l'ai pas vu,
il est sorti pendant le
tournage donc je ne voulais pas
me confondre avec les
grands chefs-d'œuvre de  le passé comme Star
Wars et 2001, euh, ça vous écrit
tous ces grands films, j'ai pris l'
attitude selon laquelle il faut simplement
s'inspirer de ces films, vous ne pouvez pas
prétendre qu'ils n'existent pas, donc je ne
voulais pas éviter les choses qui  ils avaient pris
en charge, je voulais juste embrasser que je
voulais juste être inspiré par eux et
prendre ce qu'ils ont fait et essayer de construire
dessus et de courir avec et c'est
ce que nous avons
fait, c'est parti, trois oui, vous l'êtes  deux
j'ai mon retour
un je t'aime pour toujours et je
reviens c'est très excitant pour moi
non seulement en tant que journaliste mais en tant que
public en tant que téléspectateur parce que j'ai 50 ans
et je te connais depuis longtemps donc depuis
boue Magic Mike Dallas Bers Club et
celui-ci, il semble que ce soit pour moi New Start, je veux
dire quand quand je t'ai vu maintenant dans le
film comme ça pour toi aussi, je veux dire, c'est
peut-être une nouvelle carrière, le début d'une nouvelle
carrière, la même carrière que je regarde  c'est la
même carrière, euh laissez-moi dire ceci, c'est l'une
des premières choses de sagesse que j'ai
entendues quand je suis arrivé à Hollywood. Don
Phillips me dit que j'étais comme si tu devais
me dire une chose et je ne
fais que commencer, je ne le fais pas.  Je n'ai même pas mon
premier travail ici à Hollywood, il fait un
long
trajet à cheval, euh, je veux dire, j'ai l'impression que tu
sais, je ne suis même pas à la mi-temps de ma
carrière, donc quels que soient les mouvements que
j'ai faits.  ont été perçus
comme ayant
fait, je ne le fais pas, j'ai une vision beaucoup plus large du fait
que cela fait simplement partie
de l'évolution actuelle et et et de l'
évolution si elle continue d'avancer et que
je puisse continuer à faire ce que j'aime
vous faire.  Je sais que ces mouvements ne sembleront pas si
non, mais les gens
demandent toujours aux acteurs comme si chaque rôle leur était ouvert
pendant toute leur carrière et comme si vous
regardiez ce qu'il fait dans
Interstella, je veux dire, je ne vous ai pas dit ça.
l'autre jour, quand on vous a demandé
si vous auriez pu jouer ce rôle
il y a 10 ans, mais j'aurais certainement
trouvé très difficile de ne pas choisir pour
père quelqu'un de l'âge
et de l'expérience appropriés parce que j'ai l'impression que c'est
quelque chose, euh évidemment, je pense que d'
excellents acteurs  je peux faire n'importe quoi, c'est plus de
maturité, eh bien, c'est ce que je
veux faire avec tout cela, donc
je pense qu'il y a euh certainement
du point de vue du cinéaste du
point de vue du réalisateur, c'est
comme si aucune autre chose n'était ouverte.  en tant
qu'acteur, j'acquiert plus d'expérience, c'est juste
une question de maturité de la même manière que je
prends différents films au fur
et à mesure que je vieillis, merci beaucoup pour
vous deux et félicitation
vraiment parce que je suis tellement avec
mer